octopuses are incredible creatures not
only do they have three hearts and blue
blood they're also seriously clever as
well as a large Central brain each
octopus arm has its own miniature brain
capable of acting
semi-independently one particularly
crafty specimen named Inky managed to
escape from an aquarium in New Zealand
when his tank lib was left loose he HED
himself out of the water across the
aquarium floor and escaped down a drain
to the Pacific Ocean octopuses are also
skilled camouflage artists they're able
to change their color and texture to
camouflage themselves in an instant
octopuses appear to be able to recognize
human faces it's been reported that an
octopus in one lab took a dislike to one
of the staff for no obvious reason every
time they walk past its tank the octopus
squirted a jet of water at
her